[Music]
welcome to the record where we talk
about whatever we want dante back hey
hey what's up john jj how y'all doing so
uh on the break you were talking so much
[ __ ] bro who was i just kidding
bart always talks [ __ ] i always talk
[ __ ] about everything
before we talk about anything i you know
i was just at a con recently like last
weekend and someone came to my table i
signed autographs and they said look
downtown i know i love you and rufio and
zuke and everything but [ __ ] that i i'm
here for barton joe not for you i was
like well that's like i love you on jk
news i was like damn dude what's up did
you slap him in the face and say get
your ass back in the line dude get the
[ __ ] out of here whoever did that [ __ ]
don't disrespect dante like that you're
[ __ ] like i was really impressed my
dude was did they have a picture of you
sitting in an office chair yeah no they
did but they just said i love when
you're on jk and he was i'm here for
barton jaws like they screenshotted this
right here you you you on the hot seat
and then they're like can i get your
autograph mate people do that sometimes
you're like this security
parents fall out
[ __ ] issues
i don't know what he's thinking when he
watches too much jk news he's thinking
some [ __ ] right now get him out of
here your best performance
was jk news
that's what he said damn that's crazy
you know what though this gives people a
chance to get to know the real dante and
his real opinions yeah yeah yeah
yeah let's get to know the real doctor
right now
talk about shang chi what you thought
shane you're a monster i love it great i
love the movie there it is great what do
you love about it
all of it
this guy's good bro yeah this guy's good
he's unshakeable you got to asian
paranoid what would you say i really
like the film i'm so proud of seymour
you have no critiques at all i mean i
love i love you you sound like joe biden
right now dude yeah
i love the way marvel did it i think
cimo's first leader on the film it was
great but i love how marvel kind of
uh
helped building him up bringing tony
leone in as this really international
crazy start the thing about is for
people that don't know asian cinema like
this dude is he's a legend it's a legend
he's a legend but for americans that
never seen any of his films he's not
jackie chan yeah no but when you but as
an audience member and you're watching a
movie if you don't even if you don't
know who he is you can kind of feel
how his presence yeah that's what i was
explaining to jio so she was like damn
that guy's acting is insane right i'm
like yeah i'm like have you ever watched
the departed she's like yeah i'm like
before that was infernal affairs and
with infernal affairs you have tony
leung so i'm like that's the person that
leo and matt damon studied to create
uh the departure so i'm like now you
know like like what level this fool is
at and she's like oh she don't even know
like and he's been acting for like 40
years i love her i love him so many
films he's done
in a mood for love
i mean so
bringing up a young actor and then
having a veteran actor kind of like you
know help them carry it and you can see
these posters both of them together kind
of like a co-sign too yeah coastline it
really gives time for sema to kind of
grow into the movie star he's going to
become which i thought was great and
then the action she's not a movie star
yet no he is a movie star i i
[Laughter]
he's amazing he's amazing it's just it's
great news dante says simu is not a
movie star fake news fake news i love
you you're amazing in the film
it's just so much writing on him at that
point as far as being the first asian
american there's so much writing on the
movie regardless of who was casted right
the the minute that shane she was a
project before he his agent even pushed
him to audition for it the minute that
mcu greenlit that it's like oh oh [ __ ]
this is the first asian american film
and there's a ton of our friends that
all auditioned for it simul's the one
that got it and he and he killed it yeah
he killed it i think he has the whole
package in terms of not just in the
movie but action but also like the press
that you have to do
because man you got to go on talk shows
and [ __ ] radio shows you got to do all
kinds of [ __ ] extra press so like
like i think in the movie it's literally
only like 180 of the whole package you
have to bring to um
to the movie someone should do a art art
piece of simu in a shanghai outfit
holding all of marvel and asia
like this like you know that that greek
god that holds the globe and [ __ ]
yeah on his backyard and then the
caption says don't [ __ ] up sibo
that's the pressure he had don't [ __ ] up
handling it well though i mean it's a
lot i mean like a lot of people could
crack under there i would have [ __ ] up
like crazy dude
i would you would and see what i heard
done some things that were like maybe i
wonder if they're calling them like hey
yo yo yo if he like tweets something
crazy like hey emu like don't you got to
erase that [ __ ] no matter what semu
would never [ __ ] up as hard as we would
because as soon as i get the role i'll
be like see in your face you
[ __ ] [ __ ] i would have said
that on twitter and yep and then they
waited what it felt good though
after the film came out any person that
criticized my [ __ ] i would have been
like [ __ ] you publicly that's right i
bet it was a great film you son of a
[ __ ]
i heard the sister in the film
she got casted or she got the audition
through wechat in china which sister the
sister oh simon's sister oh yeah oh [ __ ]
what what do you mean like they did a
facetime kind of thing so no like she
found out like this on wechat they were
like saying we're casting this like role
and she was like i would have used my
platform
to campaign
real issues
like my love for getting rim jobs yes
nobody talks about that very important i
was like 20 who's not even using his
platform right now for something that's
groundbreaking or about how it's
masculine to get rid of jobs yeah yeah
which nobody talks about it kind of is
everyone always feminizes it i think
seymour likes room jobs i hope he does
because it's called
it's called rusty trombones
rusty trombones dude i hope sema's
getting all the rusty trombones right
now heyman is he should be i know man do
it for asia too the one thing i didn't
like about the movie was his outfit
his outfit was crazy which one the
superhero outfit no i didn't like the
screen
it could be plain clothes it could have
been it could have been a better
superhero and hopefully it does if he
joins the avengers i hope he gets he
can't be walking around in any high tops
yeah that's that was crazy he was
wearing bands and like black jeans yeah
yeah like
maybe because the first one was just the
introduction he's just learned becoming
the supers i hope i think that's what's
happening but it's like on the second
one he needs to have some iron man [ __ ]
he did go from one scene and one like
letterman jacket and then to another
scene there's another letterman jack in
a different color oh
and i was like i was like uh he's just
gonna be switching letterman jackets the
whole time but then at the end he does
have like a superhero outfit that's like
made out of dragon scales but he
couldn't get bottoms like i know what
about the bottom i didn't get the bottom
because he didn't like the jeans you got
to do splits and [ __ ] it was crazy
though in the movie i kept watching
somehow all the characters including
totally young are wearing like tilas in
the movies
like sandals sandals
watch the movie like they all got tv's
on i'm like damn look like you guys got
tivos one of the scenes
tony young shows up during that whole
fight scene at the kind of club fight
club club and he's wearing slippers it's
those velcro sandals that everyone has
now wearing he's wearing sandals in the
club no asians got sneaky feet do you
got to keep going
bro it felt like totally on it was like
putting on those shoes today just shoot
just shoot the scene i'm wearing
slippers wait do you think that's like
out of the martial arts tradition though
because it's like i feel like in martial
as you wear devils yeah yeah you wear
tavas yeah are you really really
flexible pliable shoes which could be
kind of like that i don't go back when i
studied and i'm as you remember i'm
orange belt and cottage and cambo no
shoes no steve's a purple belt i'm a
[ __ ] profile taekwondo dude i will
take you down did you wear several
takedowns oh [ __ ] we should see you guys
to fight no no no no no no yeah we wore
shoes yeah we wear shoes
they should be wearing steel-toed boots
in karate yeah bro yeah you need armor
in that [ __ ] dude like why that's like
you don't go into a fight with bare
fists you gotta train this i used to
love wrestling shoes like i felt like i
joined the wrestling team just because i
thought the shoe was so good the shoes
are tight when you tie them it already
puts you on your toes a little bit and
there's like gripping areas so that like
you can like push off to the side
they're sick you feel like a superhero a
little bit because it grabs your makes
you look like your foots that's what
sema should have wore wrestling
wrestling shoes wrestling he was wearing
he was wearing vans the whole time
yeah it's to psychologically get people
to say hey he's like me he's one of us
he wore was way better than [ __ ] what
lou kane got to wear dude liu kang
didn't get to wear much
that's kind of fire though that luke is
kind of jacked huh lieutenant to me luke
king's the og asian superhero hundred
thousand percent and he could shoot
[ __ ] fireballs yeah yeah robin shoe
didn't get the press he got that mullet
and he looks like he'll like get some
rice like he's getting rice right now
yeah he's farming some rice and he's got
bags of rice in the storage right but he
could hold him on the shoulders yeah and
like walk you know thousands of pounds
you don't know whether to be like excuse
me can you like get a bag of rice for me
or i don't know like can kick somebody
out a lot of the fighters like you know
the stuntmen the guys at the martial
arts on the set they like to grow their
hair long like the mullet style or
something because when they do the fight
scenes it just accentuates
it's more cinematic well and the stunt
man can hide his face better too yeah
man or you can get another stunt man to
put a wig on him when it's all short
it's like damn one of our buddies played
a death dealer on what
death dealer what's the change the guy
with the mask oh
andy andy yeah he's sick bro he was
really good andy um andy and his brother
brian the lee brothers and they have a
crew called uh marshall club marshall
club they does they did a lot of like
dope ass stuff you know what like joel
rogan would watch their [ __ ] too they're
they're on the job they're like the
martial tricker guys yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah brian is the little lucky dude
that could do the splits but yeah that
guy's sick but that's her brother death
dealer is my favorite character in the
whole movie oh my that guy is bad
they're um they're they're self-taught
martial artists they just watch videos
on youtube and then they started doing
all this kung fu and stuff can change
even turn into a dragon
no but that was a joke i don't want to
ruin the movie for you but there's parts
of like something like that but he's
wearing a dragon you said dragon scales
luke can turn into a [ __ ] dragon
today's video is brought to you by a
star credit card debt can be scary man
especially when it feels like you're in
this never ending cycle of debt upstart
can help you make that final payment so
you can get ahead upstart is the fast
and easy way to pay off that debt with a
personal loan all online whether you're
paying off credit cards or consolidating
high interest debt or funding personal
expenses over half a million people have
used upstart to get one fixed monthly
payment upstart knows we're more than
just our credit score so they're
expanding access to affordable credits
unlike other lenders upstart considers
your income and current employment to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
and with just a five minute online rate
check you can see your rates up front of
loans from up to 1000 to fifty thousand
dollars
you can receive your funds as fast as
one business day after accepting your
loan that's so fast find out how upstart
can lower your monthly payments today by
going to upstart.com off the record
that's upstart.com off the record don't
forget to use the url so they know that
we sent you guys loan amounts will be
determined based off of your credit
income and certain other information
that you provide on the loan application
go to upstart.com off the record
thank you upstart
peace how come you haven't seen it steve
steven i haven't seen the movie because
i'm not going to the movie theater right
now that sounds wack as [ __ ]
why not catch a matinee dude he's trying
to not get covet dude yeah and i don't
go to the movie alone i wore a mask the
whole time i did the whole movie
that's whack dude but i was into the
movie so much i forgot about it me too
actually
i was really like
i didn't expect to be that into the
movie but i loved it i thought it was a
lot of fun yeah the movie was fun i
liked it [ __ ] so dante you didn't
like it at all i loved it
i actually loved the movie
and look i got a lot of friends in the
film and i'm so proud of them they're
great shout them out
shout outs shout outs aquafina shout out
to see how would you do it you know if
you have to rank
who gets tired
when i know people in the film it ruins
the film for me do you judge them harder
you see their no because i yeah i know
who they are so
yeah yeah so it's like oh i can't see
this as a also you guys already shoot
come on we shoot content and films and
stuff so you're already i mean i'm
already thinking about how hard was to
shoot that like i know but i want to be
like slapped into like a different world
and when i don't even know like i don't
even like films where i recognize the
actor really yeah people go oh that's a
brat pitfall my mom [ __ ] that give me a
film with that's why i like amateur porn
i love amateur porn i like the i like
the things that are like i don't even
know who these characters are right
right right right right you never fall
for an amateur porn star and then like
oh i'm gonna watch her some more yeah
and then and then i get to know them too
much and i'm like
at this point no more you don't like the
porn where there's like too much
storyline where you can tell it's fake
oh i love those oh you do like that
they're the best ones they're the best
ones do you like the real estate ones do
you like bart
nah nah that was a little too big
because it's too much work
he said off-camera yeah he said
off-camera that he liked it
god damn it guys come on tea patty's not
here to defend himself i know what you
mean though because i think i know uh so
i know simu i know ronnie too
so when you see so when you see um it
does go like it it's not like you can go
to like like let's go to a restaurant
and you just try the food for the first
time like oh this is david's restaurant
so you already got this you already you
already got david's bag you already got
the restaurants back so it is a little
bit different but because you know
we're asian and we want this first asian
superhero to do well second asian
superhero second
[Laughter]
so we you know we're already in it going
i mean
quite honestly i'm i'm in there waiting
for them to fail kinda yeah you know
like like cringy not waiting for the
like you like we used to like you can't
just enjoy the movie because you're
you're kind of like please don't [ __ ] up
the [ __ ] up so by the end of the movie i
was just happy that they didn't [ __ ] up
yeah and also i was kind of hoping cause
like i don't know how big of a priority
change she is in the marvel new universe
so i was like man i don't know if
they're gonna give them the budget
because you know to make a good film
action film you need you need the budget
so i'm like i don't know if you know
they're gonna give them the budget to
have crazy [ __ ] and then when i watch
the movie i'm like oh this is a big
budget for sure now what's great is what
means even more ultimately as things
ripple out after the movie's out it
became number one from the country it's
over 270 million which is rivaling what
free guys doing so like now you know
what i'm saying like finally there's
something with asian stars that's kind
of like at that get the sequel man it's
going to have a crazy rich moment kind
of crazy moment before
the superhero
i see it okay
but the more i guess it's more like the
more you tally up these like wins yeah
the more they're willing to invest on
hopefully projects that you know are
well that's what they wanted to do they
saw crazy rich asians go insane yeah
yeah and they're like [ __ ] yeah we'll do
we'll do it
because that's the end of the day it's
like it's racist i'm like it's not it's
a money game it's not racist it's
business it's like we just haven't
proved and asians
have improved like their money spending
power or their staff we got to just
build systems that maybe didn't does not
open in china
no i don't think not yet no i think i
think yeah i don't know if they're going
to but something happened like like
politicism and
i didn't ask my girlfriend from mainland
i was like why do you think he's going
to play in china she's like i was going
to play good because of you know oh
she's from china she's from all right
she's like long just like not even like
political she's like there's a strange
thing she said about the one thing
that'd be kind of strange i don't think
over and over she was talking to friends
in china is the youth talk you know the
father-son relationship and the kind of
youth kind of battling the elders is
kind of
not cool culture huh edgy for the cult
for the mainland cultures like you're
not really ever supposed to don't
disrespect your parents no
i'm like
what i thought yeah they didn't like uh
the wizard like magic and [ __ ] like that
the fu manchu like that was like his
nickname or something like that too
the the main the bad guy and i think
that was like some issues there but i
don't know but they took that out there
i mean like they rewrote that into a
good job of explaining that what about
um ben kingsley in it he was dumb
yeah he was a pleasant surprise yeah he
was great and how it came back from
iron man that's cool yeah they all tied
everything together very nicely oh i
guess cemu criticized china at some
point and they found and he said
taiwan's a country and then now like
that [ __ ] did he say that not enough
that's what john cena did yeah he didn't
even say he was just like taiwan's the
first country to see it and then he got
blasted wow that's the tough part about
being a superstar then i'm like i'd [ __ ]
it up like crazy like dude we already
have i know because like just not
acting's not
not we're not even superstars that we
[ __ ] it up like crazy bro and our degree
is a celebrity at arctic and celebrities
like
it's a good little thing because you
like you you got it you're way celebrity
that doesn't even me i'm like right
under the radar that i could not get too
in trouble but like just a little above
that you say some [ __ ] you're [ __ ] up
if you got 200 million banking on you
right so you got to kill it out the
press then like [ __ ] i don't know
mattel or whatever got a billion dollars
banking on you for the action figures
that's true you cannot [ __ ] up like
everyone
is like i wouldn't be surprised if you
[ __ ] up and they [ __ ] assassinate you
you can [ __ ] up at any moment
like back in the day when i was like a
kid actor there's no social media like
to [ __ ] up you have to do it like to be
on a tv show getting interviewed or a
reporter and it'd be
an opportunity for you to [ __ ] say
something to [ __ ] up yeah but now you
have the opportunity every second of the
day is just like any moment like i can't
even resist sometimes we no we didn't
even gotta [ __ ] up in the in the future
we already [ __ ] up in the past we'd
have to wipe out
all the data of everything of us but you
guys have said like and i love that it's
about 10 dillinger too like they you
guys have set up your personality
the scope of what you can say because if
you're scum already and they expect you
to be a scumbag the problem with that is
if you have a resume of [ __ ] you also
never get the good jobs
we're not gonna get a disney contract no
but that you're not gonna get
but you'll you can get like what do you
think but you can get like uh comedy
central
i mean disney does own everything
there's somewhere in the disney thing
you all can get it they probably have
like an edgier property or something
like that or they'll give you guys a
cameo one day i want the freedom to talk
about porn i don't think they'll allow
does disney have a porn department does
disney have fester they should that's
the new frontier they need to grow with
their fan base how about that they put
enough dicks in the little mermaid to
get there i think
didn't they i mean there's [ __ ] all
over the place she was wild dude it was
absolutely crazy they need to get better
animators for uh disney porn like
parodies pixar yeah it sucks biggest
issues that's not great princess porn
who are you looking up as far as like
this i mean sometimes it pops up and
then you see like there's amateur hours
there's no white getting railed by the
seven dwarves wait is is this like
cosplay stuff that you're looking at joe
no like animation
and then the the artist i say animation
porn don't really do it for me me
neither that's the only way i get all
you're missing out bro
what's it called
hentai because i i agree with you i've
looked it up before to see if it works
for me i'm like i don't know i don't
think this works for me you know what
does work for me though when they zoom
in no no when they zoom in when they
zoom into the chick right
and then when they do the anime porn
that zooms into the chick and then when
the buttons start vibrating to let you
know the titties are too big for the
shirt i like that oh i like that i like
that as well i like that as well
some people have no worries some people
have sent me some porn from some of the
cartoon characters i've blessed doing
porn
oh no like like prince
[Laughter]
dude was he laying it down yeah i didn't
can't watch it dude i can't watch come
on dude pull up some videos
no no just it was just like animation of
it or like images of it was more the
ones that they sent me were more like
still images
check if dante got some deep fakes bro
yeah i don't know which one prince zuko
is but oh my god that's him and another
man
goddamn
[Laughter]
[Applause]
a power bottom with this picture that's
him huh i'm not looking at you i can't
see
i can't see it here bert yo people are
correct damn that's you dante not me
dang don't take you um bro
yeah like i mean it's not a bad thing
low bmi you know nice big dicks one of
those videos
that uh this actually this is one of
those videos if dante makes it to the
next level i'm in trouble you're gonna
be texting us because this happened
before hey i just let you know i got
this big network deal you guys need to
scrub the channel and take my name out
of all the titles
every time we have someone here and they
go to the next level we always get that
text right never [ __ ] come back as a
guest which one's friend zuko i don't
know
because this is three guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you